our new connector
is called lightning so now we have
thunderbolt and lightning in our
connector strategy
this connector is a modern connector for
the next decade for the past 10 years
apple's lightning connector has been the
main solution for charging and
transferring data on the iphone but now
it's clearly the number one weakness in
terms of iphone hardware and for the
past week i've been doing a bunch of
research and i think i've finally come
to the conclusion that there's a good
chance that apple's upcoming iphone 14
pro will come with a usbc port so in
this video i'm going to provide you with
some solid proof for my prediction based
on leaks and rumors as well as what
apple has done in the past and what
they're currently doing right now which
is giving us some major hints at why the
time is right for usbc so let's get
right into it back in september mark
german claimed that the iphone 14 would
feature a complete redesign
and i talked a lot about that in my
recent video where i had some custom
renders made for me by shailesh on
twitter and even earlier back in august
mark german wrote a very interesting
article from bloomberg titled it's time
for apple to fix its confusing device
charger strategy and within the article
he mentioned that lightning has served
apple well since 2012 but usbc has
become the default and the pros of
moving to usbc are stronger than the
cons by moving the iphone to usbc apple
will have a unified connector with its
macs and countless other devices and
keep in mind that those words come from
the most reliable apple leaker out there
with an 87 accuracy rating covering over
500 rumors but adding on to that we also
saw a similar leak from leaks apple pro
claiming that usbc might finally be
coming to the iphone 14 pro and
according to a sources there are three
reasons for why apple could be switching
to usbc
transfer speeds legal troubles and the
environment cost as we all know transfer
speeds with usbc are much faster than
lightning which is limited to usb 2.0
speeds and as far as legal troubles both
the biden harris administration and the
european union are pushing for usb-c
ports on all devices and in terms of the
environment apple could switch to usb-c
while at the same time removing the
cable from the box to help save the
environment and obviously save apple
cache so with that said we already have
leaks pointing to apple switching to
usb-c on the iphone 14 pro but i've got
even better evidence for why this makes
so much sense but first we've got to
take a look at all the three major
reasons for why apple gave the usbc port
to the ipad pro back in 2018. before
that point people were complaining about
the lightning port for years saying that
it was single handedly holding the ipad
pro back from being a true pro device
and as for the second reason usb-c was
required for some of the features that
apple was planning to give the ipad pro
like connecting fast external ssds to
help with professional editing as well
as connecting to external monitors which
is a feature that is not supported by
lightning and apple even showed off the
usbc port being used for various things
like connecting digital cameras for easy
file transfers charging an iphone
connecting to an audio mixer and once
again to a display and the third and
final reason for adding usbc was that
apple knew that they wanted to up the
base price of the ipad pro up to 799
dollars and there's no way that they
could have gotten away with it without
adding usbc to solve all of those
limitations and complaints and if you
really think about it every time apple
added usb-c to an ipad it came with a
price increase like the ipad air 4 in
2020 which got a hundred dollars more
expensive as well as the ipad mini 6
last year also a hundred dollars more
and part of that price increase was to
help compensate for lost revenues from
apple's lightning port because if you
didn't already know apple makes royalty
fees from every accessory out there that
uses a lightning port through their mfi
program so with that said before i
explain why it makes so much sense for
apple to switch to usbc on the iphone 14
pro models let me break down how i think
apple plans to make this usbc switch
happen to start i believe that apple is
planning on raising the base price of
the iphone 14 pro models because i don't
know if you remember or not but before
apple revealed the iphone 13 lineup it
was rumored that they would raise iphone
prices because their main chip supplier
tsmc
increased the pricing on their silicon
chip wafers and since we didn't get an
iphone price increase last year i
believe that it's coming this year
specifically with the iphone 14 pro
models getting a hundred dollars more
expensive however the problem is that
apple needs to justify the price
increase and the way that they've always
done this is with a full redesign which
for the upcoming iphone 14 has been
rumored for months now including the new
pill shaped cutout to replace the notch
on only the pro models as you can see in
this render that i had created by
shailesh so with that said many people
will gladly pay an extra hundred dollars
for that new hole punch display design
that looks very fresh but on the other
hand there are some people who could
care less about the notch since they've
gotten used to it over the past couple
of years and to them spending the extra
cash isn't worth it so apple would need
something else to entice people into
accepting the base price increase and i
fully believe that it could be the
switch to usbc because if you think
about it people have been asking for
usb-c for years now and apple has been
holding off for so long that if apple
made the switch right now then the
majority of consumers would be totally
shocked and blown away by this move by
apple and by doing this it could
single-handedly get people who
previously hated on apple for years to
finally soften up a bit and even
consider switching from an android to
the iphone and that's not even
mentioning the millions of people with
older iphones who will finally have a
great reason to upgrade to the 14 pro
just because of that usbc port that will
make their life so much easier if they
already have a bunch of other usbc
cables lying around so even if switching
to usbc would mean lost revenue for
apple from their lightning ecosystem the
vast number of new iphone sales because
of that new usb-c port would more than
make up for the lost revenue and if you
don't know what i mean by lost revenue
apple's lightning port is part of the
mfi program which means that every time
any company out there creates an
accessory like a lightning cable or
adapter apple charges a licensing
royalty for that lightning connector
bringing in a bunch of extra revenue and
that right there is probably why apple
has stuck to lightning for so long
because if they suddenly ditched it they
would lose out on all of that mfi
royalty revenue within a couple of years
but thankfully apple has been working on
the absolute perfect solution to this
problem which will make it much easier
to ditch lightning and that is of course
apple's new magsafe ecosystem for the
iphone if you didn't already know both
the mac safe case module and the maxsafe
charger module are also part of the mfi
program which means that apple makes
money for every single mac safe
accessory sold regardless of whether it
supports charging or not so max save is
already replacing the mfi profits from
apple's lightning connector and in my
opinion it's going to make much more
money than lightning since magsafe is
modern and it's many times more useful
in fact we've already made three videos
on useful mac safe accessories and my
absolute favorite iphone accessory i've
ever purchased in my life is this
magsafe vent mount charger for my car
which is incredibly convenient but
having max life in the mfi program is
absolutely genius for apple because it
has nothing to do with the wired
charging port since it's on the back of
the iphone so apple can easily switch to
usbc and still make a ton of revenue
from max safe mfi royalty fees so the
point that i'm trying to make is that
apple isn't going to ditch lightning
until they successfully create an
alternative ecosystem that will bring in
extra mfi royalty revenue from their
iphone and i fully believe that apple
has already achieved that goal with the
new max safe ecosystem and they're now
finally ready to begin ditching the
lightning port and making my point even
more convincing apple has recently added
magsafe charging support to both their
new airpods 3 and airpods pro cases and
even better the most reliable leaker out
there mark german believes that apple is
adding wireless magsafe support to the
ipad pro later this year to further push
the magsafe ecosystem forward and to
make it even crazier mark mentioned that
apple plans on giving the apple watch
magnetic max safe charger support as
well so if all of this comes to light it
proves that apple is going to be fully
invested in making max safe the new mfi
money maker to replace the old lightning
standard but now with all that said i
have one last reason for apple adding
usbc to the iphone 14 pro and i think
that this one is the final nail in the
coffin when apple finally added usb-c to
the ipad pro the main reason was that
lightning was severely limiting what the
ipad could do and i fully believe that
we've finally reached that point with
the iphone's lightning port with the
iphone 13 pro you can now record prores
video which takes up a massive amount of
storage space specifically six gigabytes
per minute for 4k prores
but the problem is that the lightning
port still only supports usb 2 speeds
meaning that transferring those prores
files takes forever for example michael
tobin on youtube did a prores first look
video and he said that it took between
one to one and a half hours to transfer
160 gigs of 4k prores video which
translates to only around 26 minutes of
footage and because of that super slow
lightning port transfer speed he said
that it's probably gonna discourage
users from recording in prores at all
but wait it gets even worse because
we've been recently getting some very
solid leaks and rumors from analysts
like mingchequo that point to the iphone
14 pro coming with a brand new 48
megapixel main camera that can shoot 8k
video yes i said 8k and i believe it's
gonna work using the same prores format
since apple is building prores encoders
and decoders into both their iphone and
mac chips to make shooting editing and
playing back prores footage use much
less power and this finally brings me to
a tweet from mkbhd on twitter mentioning
that ak prores video would use 24
gigabytes of storage space per minute so
yes the quality is gonna be insane but
if apple sticks to the lightning port on
the iphone 14 pro it'll literally take
over an hour to transfer only around six
minutes of 8k prores footage which is
completely unacceptable and unrealistic
and based on that final point along with
everything that i already mentioned in
this video including the leaks and
rumors i believe that there's a pretty
good chance that we will finally see the
usbc ports on the upcoming iphone 14 pro
and if you totally disagree with me go
ahead and comment your thoughts down
below but if you enjoyed this video
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]